Well, I have so many.
I remember that
when I was a kid,
I used to go to the
movies with my mom
and watch up to four
movies in a row.
Probably, it has to be
the very first Star Wars
movie that I saw.
Everybody that knows me know
I love Independence Day.
It was-- Mani Ratnam
who's a famous director,
his movie called Bombay.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
It was to see 101 Dalmatians.
My cousin took me
to a matinee of E.T.
Seeing The Sound
of Music when I was
11 years old for my birthday.
There is no better
moment than Meg Ryan's
faking an orgasm scene.
That just took my
imagination to new heights.
Singing, the colors, the entire
screen just blew my mind.
I'll never forget feeling
the larger-than-life wash
of storytelling take over me.
It felt like an
all-you-can-eat buffet.
My mom packed us little
Ziploc baggies of candy.
They were like, we are
not buying anything
from the concession stand,
because it's too expensive.
The first time I saw that movie
was actually the first time
I went on a date as a teenager.
All the seats were taken,
except the front row.
So, of course, the worst
seat in the house, and I
was just staring up.
And my neck was killing
me, and I didn't care.
I remember driving all the
way out to an art house cinema
so that my parents
could sneak me in
to watch Chen Kaige's
Farewell My Concubine--
Yes!
Which is totally an
inappropriate movie
for like a six-year-old.
The entire theater
was in an uproar,
just convulsions of
laughter and screaming.
It was the first time that
I watched a movie where
I actually cried, and I
actually went on the journey
as if I was there.
And it was like the first time I
realized, oh, this is powerful.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
I had all the action figures.
I had the whole
Millennium Falcon,
and I would enjoy playing
with all my Star Wars
action figures.
And little did I know, I
think, that doing so, it really
is the seeds to your own
storytelling ability.
It was just like you wanted
to replay that scene again,
right then in that moment, when
you were at the movie theater.
[MUSIC PLAYING]